[Applause]
overnight Joe Biden went to the back of
the pack to frontrunner as soon as the
polls closed in the south
Biden's carried the momentum from his
massive victory in South Carolina a few
days ago well it may be over for the
other guy so laughing the folks of
Virginia North Carolina Tennessee
Minnesota supporters of two candidates
who dropped out of the race to endorse
five needs once faltering campaign teeth
Budaj and Amy Klobuchar seemed to boost
him throughout Super Tuesday with the
news that billionaire Michael Bloomberg
has bowed out of the presidential race
Joe Biden has not only lost a competitor
but he's gained a powerful financial
backer it's the best news he could have
possibly gotten after a night that
started with him winning Virginia and
then North Carolina then came Tennessee
and Alabama in quick succession
baigan won Texas the second largest
state to vote on Super Tuesday and his
astounding victory in Massachusetts was
a massive setback to Elizabeth Warren
who represents the state in the Senate
she made clear though her battle was far
from over
so here's my advice cast a vote that
will make you proud
cast a vote from your heart
vote for the person you think will make
the best president of the United States
the front-runner going into Super
Tuesday stayed in the fight Bernie
Sanders easily won his home state of
Vermont along with significant victories
in Colorado and Utah most importantly
although it will be hours and possibly
days before all votes are in
he is the projected winner in the
critical state of California with its
huge block of Delegates but tonight I
tell you with absolute confidence we are
going to win the Democratic nomination
and we are going to defeat the most
dangerous president in the history of
this country and the results on Super
Tuesday appear to reflect a new focus
among Democratic Party voters in
choosing a presidential nominee
despite the debate about competing
platforms support is being increasingly
determined by one single issue who would
be the most suitable candidate to defeat
Donald Trump John Hendren al-jazeera
Charlotte North Carolina